dwyer says that the team didn't see
anything during its visits to suggest a
lab accident
quote now whether we were shown
everything you can never know
the group wasn't designed to go and do a
forensic examination of lab practice
the basic point for us here is there has
to be some intermediate right
this virus knows the trick of infecting
humans extremely well
right it is it is post adaptation
where that adaptation took place isn't
pangolins it doesn't appear
it uh we don't have another
candidate that has emerged we don't have
a human population in which it could
have learned this and so in some sense
the laboratories in wuhan are one
possible intermediate right they are not
the only possible intermediate and
what heather mentioned a few minutes ago
the who in
collaboration with china appears to be
steering us towards
another um hypothesis i'm just going to
give you one brief
one couple minutes from this interview
between
uh becky anderson of cnn and
uh peter dassack of this who commission
who you will have heard us mentioned
before okay show the clip zach
well we're talking about something very
different right now
than um you know a package of um
frozen fish from somewhere else in the
world we're talking about the origins of
sarsko v2 the covet outbreak in a market
in the likely center of it the early
spreading of that outbreak
and what we see though when we visit
that market is a place that sold a lot
of frozen products
not just the typical things we would buy
a supermarket but also
frozen animal products from animal farms
in southeast asia and inside china
and there's a really striking piece of
evidence that was mentioned today
in the press conference that in those
products were included wildlife
meat and carcasses from animals that we
know are susceptible to
coronaviruses and also that the supply
chains come from places
um in china where we know the sars
coronavirus ii related viruses are in
other words
a direct link from the potential
bat origins of this brush which most
scientists believe is true
into wuhan market now scientists in
china tested those carcasses and they
were negative
so that's good but we don't know what
else was there
we don't really know if there were live
animals there's no evidence of that but
we don't know
and we don't know how many of these
animals were part of that frozen
market or even other types of meat so
you know to many of us on the team
it was a a clear clue as to what may
have happened but it was one of the
the the pathways that we thought was
um more likely than others for sure
let me just be quite clear about this
then it's one of those pathways
that might be more likely you say and
that's
an agreement uh that you made as a team
but i'm struggling all right to
understand
say again keep going then
specific evidence that you have to
support
this contention sir with respect
well the specific evidence comes from
the work that china's been doing that
chinese scientists have been doing
from really day one of the outbreak so
around about january the first
scientists from china cdc went into the
market and started swabbing
the market they looked at sewage they
looked at stalls where they sold
food they looked at the stones where the
people were positive for coronavirus
they spent about a month on their
swabbing testing
over 900 samples collected a really
thorough deep
study and most of the animals products
had gone
but there were some still there and if
there were there weren't live animals in
the market we
we think mainly aquatic animals but we
don't know there is
there are rumors of of live mammals in
that market
but what was really intriguing was this
find of of carcasses of animals
mammals actually ferret badgers which
are a type of animal that's widely eaten
across
southeast asia which we know has the
capacity
all right so um that was peter dasak
and i we will put a link to that um
that little interview uh on in the
description
of this video you should check out the
whole thing um it's rather incoherent
what i believe is not said anywhere is
that peter dasak
they say he's a zoologist on the who
team
peter dassack is more than a zoologist
he is also head
of eco health alliance which has been
deeply involved in the funding pathway
for gain of function research in
including sending millions of dollars to
wuhan to study these very viruses so he
has
an intense conflict of interest but go
ahead
the description of him is a zoologist
across all of the major media platforms
whenever they mention him
is um is beginning to feel
intentionally misleading it is true that
he's a zoologist and that is
that describes uh his training from many
decades ago
but what his work has been the way that
he has made a living
for all of his recent history is as
president of an organization
that specifically works on gain of
function research on coronaviruses on
bats
um and works with the wun um institute
so um to be clear
we are not looking to blame anybody for
the uh the covet 19 pandemic there is
fault we believe in at least the
recklessness
of the gain of function research which
if it didn't cause this outbreak
certainly could
cause a very serious outbreak so there
is something about this
that requires our scrutiny but at some
level what we have
here is a failure to appreciate the
hazard of gain of function research and
that's a hazard that's a
failure on the part of the international
scientific community
so the point though is dasic has
the strong incentive to favor
any uh hypothesis other than
a lab leak and so the fact that he's on
the who team i believe he's the only
american on the who team
really raises the question about um what
sort of investigation this is but
the key um the key here is that you can
see
dasic is very excited about the
possibility what he says is
evidence of another pathway
basically that there were um frozen
ferret badger steaks
in the wuhan uh seafood market
and what the reason that this is
exciting
to dasek and others on the
who team is that ferret badgers
are mustelids which are another
creature which sars kovi ii can
infect so we have seen
unlike the case with uh pangolins to
which stars kovi ii is not well adapted
czar's kobe 2 is also not well adapted
to bats
um but it has spread like wildfire
through
mink farms so minks are mustelids and
the virus not only infects makes we've
seen it in effect other things like big
cats and zoos
but what it does not do is spread from
them
the case in minks is exceptional so
minks actually catch the disease
and they spread it very much like humans
it's well adapted to people it's well
adapted to minx
and ferret badgers is a small
clade of closely related creatures in
southeast asia
allow me to just do a tiny bit of
phylogenetic description here so this
from
one of the the tomes of mammals it's
it's a little dated at this point
um but this is this is the second second
volume of walker's
mammals walker's mammals of the world
the one that includes the carnivora
which is one
clade uh within the carnivore we have as
you have said
the mustelids which includes broadly
speaking the weasels irmans stoats minks
ferrets and polecats
um and then also within the mustellet is
the genus melo gale
which the common name for which is
ferret badgers so you know it's not a
not a misspeaking it's neither a ferret
nor a badger although it is closely
related to a ferret and you know this is
this is true across a lot of common
names right that you end up with like
i don't know what it is i'm going to
kind of call it both things and
um but both ferrets and badgers are
mustelids
so um it is it is one of the
rare cases where these two things show
up in the right clade
so yeah spotted skunks anyway
it's it's a it's a cool place skunks
have been moved out of the mustelds
not meaningfully including the spotted
skunks i believe so okay
um so i just i just had a couple
sentences to read from walkers here
about the third badgers
also at the point that this book was
published in the 90s there were we
thought there were three species now we
think there are five
you know this is a splitter lumper
distinction that is not of much interest
to anyone
outside of the people doing this work
certainly a very little interest to the
fairfags themselves
actually um so far um
the ferret badgers are found in wooded
country in grassland they climb on
occasion
um ferret badgers are savage and
fearless when provoked or oppressed and
have an offensive odor
and a ferret badge so the diet is
omnivorous and is known to include small
vertebrates insects earthworms and fruit
and a ferret badger is sometimes welcome
to enter a native hut
because of its destruction of insect
pests
so welcome in the places where they live
which is as you say sort of broadly
throughout
south asia southeast asia so a couple
things to say
one peter dasik reports that these
things are widely
eaten um i don't know how widely they
are eaten apparently you found evidence
that they are eaten
uh by some people yeah i think let's see
the iucn red list
if i can find it here um uh
so the iucn um being
the what does it stand for why isn't it
on the page i don't know
um the iucn red list did suggest that
they
that the one very widely distributed
species which is the only one that is in
china including the range of uh
including within the range of wuhan does
get eaten sometimes but this is a long
okay a long period this is the chinese
fair badger okay so the point is
you know so let's put peter dasik's
motives aside
peter dasik for whatever reason does not
find the lab leak hypothesis credible
and has in fact portrayed
uh us and other people as conspiracy
theorists for even considering it but
really the point is we need an
intermediate
um lab the lab would be one obvious
intermediate
in fact the use of mustelids in the lab
is likely
ferrets would have been a possible
creature in which
cereal passaging might have been done
which would very well explain why this
is so easily infecting and spreading
between
minks we don't know that to be the case
but it's possible
but in any case the fact that it spreads
in mustelids means that if they can find
a mistelled link
that okay in principle there could have
been an epidemic
of the ancestor of sars kovi
ii in ferret badgers
in let's say some other part of china or
some other place where they exist
and then he proposes that they could
have that in fact there was ferret
badger meat in the wuhan market he says
it was tested
negative which is good i don't know why
he regards that
as good this virus came from somewhere
and this would be as good an answer as
any if it was true
so anyway the link would be
the frozen ferret badger stakes having
come from infected animals
where the function of
infecting human cells was gained in this
intermediate
resulted in the transportation of the
virus to wuhan where
it then infected somebody in the market
or infected somebody who took steak home
from there
now this is highly unlikely for one
thing
we would have to imagine if that was the
expected route
then it would have been effectively sars
cov2 that came off that stake because
if it wasn't then there would have been
an evolutionary phase in wuhan for which
we have no evidence
so it effectively has to have already
done all of that evolving at the point
that it arrives in wuhan on the stake
and what we know is that these viruses
don't transmit effectively this way it's
not to say some viruses couldn't and
it's not to say it's completely
impossible
but the idea that this came off of a
frozen stake is pretty unlikely given
how
overwhelming the transmission by uh
airborne and aerosolized particles seems
to be of this virus so
in any case this does have the sense of
the who team
grasping at straws they don't want to
look at the lab leak hypothesis for
which the evidence has gotten stronger
and stronger it's not a settled question
but it is stronger
and they do want anything else that
could take the place
of that missing link in the logical
chain and so
they are now putting you know one way to
say this
is um frozen ferret badger steaks are
the new pangolins
all right um so just to just to wrap
that up
a tiny bit more uh zach if you would
show my screen just for a minute
three days ago on february 10th nature
published in their news section
major stones unturned covet origin
search must continue after who report
say scientists investigation team rules
that idea that the coronavirus came from
a laboratory leak
but offers two hypotheses popular in
chinese media
well that um sub headline actually
is not an accurate portrayal of what's
in the piece sak if i might have my
screen back here i'm just going to read
from two paragraphs
lower down in that report quote another
focus of the who's investigation was the
idea that the virus leaked from a lab
a scenario that the team found unlikely
incidentally unlikely and rules out are
not the same
peter ben emberick a food safety and
zonoses scientist with the who in geneva
switzerland who headed the investigation
said at the press conference that the
team had conducted extensive discussions
with staff
at the wuhan institute of virology which
has been at the center of the
speculation and similar labs nearby
he said a leak is unlikely because the
virus is not known to scientists before
december 2019.
dwyer that's a medical virologist at new
south wales health pathology in sydney
also a member of the who team
dwyer says again still quoting from this
uh nature news article from
february 10th about the who report
dwyer says that the team didn't say
dwyer says that the team didn't see
anything during its visits to suggest a
lab accident
quote now whether we were shown
everything you can never know
the group wasn't designed to go and do a
forensic examination of lab practice
end quote may be true
if so why not how is it that they were
going in order to
actually contemplate awe and assess all
of the hypotheses on the table
of which there is considerable evidence
pointing to the idea of a lab leak
if they were not actually ready to let's
see
wasn't designed to go and do a forensic
examination of lab practice
who then is and so what effectively this
does
is it conflates an absence of evidence
well
we weren't equipped to do that
investigation and the people who were
there say it didn't happen
right now i will say were it the case
that this virus did not emerge from that
laboratory
you would have the people in the
laboratory virtually certain that this
had not
been on their watch they would sound the
same way they do which is part of why
you can't look at them and say
listen to how they sound that's evidence
they would sound the same
either way well they would sound the
same and
i believe the the uh the
strong implication is that they would
behave very
very differently now nobody knows what
goes on inside
you know internal chinese government
discussions of these things
but the fact is the behavior of the
laboratory has been incredibly
suspicious it has been the opposite of
transparent
and under normal conditions you would
imagine
that were you to run such a lab
you know zhengli herself
says that when this virus first emerged
she didn't get a wink of sleep
for fear that it had escaped from her
lab right and then she reports i
didn't and therefore i you know relaxed
but the point is she considered it
plausible right
were you to find yourself in this
situation where you knew that it didn't
come from your lab because you'd never
seen that sequence before
it's out in the world it's doing
trillions of dollars of damage to the
world economy and killing millions of
human beings
you would be very inclined to show
your books and say didn't come from here
take a look right even if that wouldn't
be your normal impulse because
everything is riding on this question
including the future of this lab so the
idea that they would want to keep
you know so in any case what i'm
what they did was delete a major
database
which would have contained likely
contained evidence they haven't shown
notebooks they haven't opened their
freezers the who
commission says uh lab league very
unlikely but of course we're not in a
position really to have done that
forensic work
right and the spokesperson from the who
team not the leader of it but the spokes
the the main media spokesperson darling
is directly tied in funding the research
that was being done in that lab
right so in any case all of this again
raises the specter of can we just please
have an open investigation
every hypothesis on the table including
frozen ferret badger steaks that's a
hypothesis but at this moment what that
is is a hypothesis
with no evidence like the sum total of
the evidence for that hypothesis
is ferret badger stakes were apparently
present and tested negative
right you know i i don't know why
i'm sure that that dasek wasn't thinking
this but whenever you say frozen ferret
badger steaks
i imagine one with a stick i imagine
actually a fair uh frozen ferret badger
popsicle
and um you know maybe maybe you're more
inclined or more
likely to get the virus by licking a
slowly thawing for frozen ferret badger
popsicle than you would be by frying it
up and
i think maybe you do both actually maybe
you you
you lick the frozen ferret badger
popsicle until it thaws and then you
fry it and then you eat it still i think
it's unlikely to transmit that way i
think you would have to
you would have to shave it and make
particles which you sort of
oh aerosolized frozen ferret badger
steak popsicles yeah or snow cones no i
mean actually that sounds pretty
parsimonious to me yeah
yeah yeah the whole thing is uh is
rather rather remarkable
but hey we've got a number of
you know did it evolve somewhere else
that's a hypothesis right it's a
hypothesis that involves a train it
makes a prediction there's a population
somewhere else that had an epidemic that
we haven't found yet in spite of the
fact that
the entire world is looking it's looking
like we're all looking
right yes um did it start in um
ferret badgers who were then transported
maybe live maybe that's what happened
live to the
muhan seafood market and they coughed on
somebody and we have no evidence of it
because before being turned into ferret
badger popsicles well here's the thing
they've got the frozen steaks
you and i regard the likelihood of
frozen steaks it's pretty low because
the stuff the likelihood of them having
passed this having passed it on that way
but there were also live animals in the
market
he waffles over whether or not there
were any live ferret badgers but
um nonetheless let's say okay the
hypothesis that it was fair at badgers
in some other part of china
that is a viable hypothesis right what
does it predict it predicts
a population of ferret badgers who a
probably are still circulating this
virus we should be able to find them
right b will show uh
you know immunity to it in other words
we'll be able to see that they have
antibodies to this very thing
so in any case we could probably come up
with a dozen predictions from that
hypothesis well let's go to it that's a
hypothesis on the list but so is the lab
right so anyway that's how all of this
should be should be dealt with we're
looking for a missing link we should all
agree on that that missing link can be
anything from a laboratory
to a population of mustelids and
all of these things make predictions
that's the nature of a hypothesis
and a proper investigation would simply
sort through these things and at the end
of the day
we would very likely get the answer but
we're not going to get it by
saying you know that hype there's no
evidence for that hypothesis why is
there no evidence because we didn't look
for evidence okay
that's not well to the degree that we
looked for evidence we asked the people
who would have the most to lose if that
hypothesis were true and they said it
isn't true and so we said okay we trust
them don't you trust them how dare you
not trust them what are you cynophobic
yes come on right exactly okay
good well i think i think we covered the
topic i think i do too hopefully that
makes it clearer why the discussion is
moving in the direction it's moving and
what is really at stake in the various
claims
[Music]